salut j'ai juste de rentrer de tournai
narbonne et la dernière vidéo j'ai mise
en ligne qui doit être juste ici est
sorti il ya précisément trois heures
ayant toute la durée du trajet répondu
aux commentaires
et franchement ça méritait de faire une
vidéo gi trois types de réponses
[Musique]
tous ceux qui sont nés en 2002 qui me
sont tombés dessus en mode est vrai mais
ça marche pas sur 2002 ce qui est vrai
c'est un oubli de ma part je m'excuse
j'ai pas penser à cette possibilité là
c'était d'ailleurs le même cas pour 1991
ils ont été moins violents et moi vite
pour pallier à ça j'ai mis un
commentaire que j'épinglais qui a servi
à rien rien mais ça sert à rien en fait
d'épingler un message puisque en fait
personne ne lit par contre j'ai appris
un truc si je veux qu'ils aient masse
commentaires il suffit de faire
volontairement une petite erreur et ça
reproduirait le même truc donc en fait
là j'ai décroché d'habitude je lis
toujours tous les commentaires j'essaye
de répondre un petit peu et où la lie et
en fait c'est trop c'est du spam
la deuxième réaction qui était un petit
peu plus étonnantes c'était de trouver
en fait le concept débile
alors je peux le comprendre un kit
laisse pas le concept attention les
débiles il y avait beaucoup qui me
reprocher que ce n'était pas vraiment du
mentalisme tempête y avait une
explication rationnelle qui avait un peu
de maths de cacher derrière du coup ça
va passer nulle et tout ça c'est marrant
se dire que dans la vidéo je dis
clairement au début je vais faire un
truc qui va vous bluffez enfin peut-être
l'idée c'est de vous surprendre
peut-être c'est parti et en fin de vidéo
jeudi j'espère que cette expérience de
logique puisque c'est une expérience
logique est un fondement mathématiques
derrière on est bien d'accord avec ça
d'autres vidéos comme ça qui sont des
vidéos un petit peu de divertissement
logique alors je me suis je vais faire
cette vidéo tual pas beaucoup dormi le
sort du train mais j'ai allumé direct la
caméra en fait cette vidéo ça fait quand
même pas mal de temps que je la réfléchi
que je l'écris que je lis les tournées
du coup et j'ai mis quatre jours à la
montée c'est le maximum que j'ai mis
pour monter une vidéo j'ai essayé de
faire beaucoup d'effet à l'intérieur
même un peu de trekking sûr mais mike et
le but de la vidéo et de cette série que
je voulais lancer
c'était du divertissement un samedi
matin peut-être une fois par mois
faire un truc un peu rigolo un peu
surprenant mais qui peut s'expliquer
juste le principe d'un truc rigolo et b
team crois tu me crois pas ça m'a bien
détendu donc je pense que j'en referai
plus voilà c'était la petite annonce du
jour on va continuer sur les astuces on
va continuer moi quand je bloque des
gens du buzz grain mais j'en referai pas
des comme ça et coûte peut-être que je
me suis planté et c'est pas grave en
tout cas merci à la 3éme catégorie
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont bien aimé la
vidéo c'est cool ça me faisait choc
même si j'ai moins vu vos messages noyé
dans tous les commentaires de ces nuls
ça marche pas a oui parce qu'il ya aussi
une quatrième petite catégorie
ça c'est l'ultime c'est tout ce qu'ils
font c'est de la merde ça marche pas
parce que eux se sont trompés dans leurs
calculs le départ il y avait un calcul
il y avait une soustraction à faire
c'était le seul truc et quand tu te
plantes de la soustraction ça ça arrive
hier ça m'arrive aussi mais vient pas
m'insulter moi parce que tu t'es trompé
toi c'était censé être un petit format
celle que je voulais lancer j'en avais
une autre sur un concept de 360 degrés
une autre sur un concept de une espèce
de verbe on joue ben lee vu le temps que
ça me prend par rapport à ça ajoute bly
et je note précieusement qu'une petite
vidéo juste pour vous amuser en début de
week-end c'est pas le top ne voyait
aucune agressivité dans cette vidéo vous
devez même voir que je suis plutôt amusé
en fait par ce qui vient de se passer
c'est est révélateur de plein droit
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner ou à vous
réabonner si vous souhaitez vous abonner
à cause de la vidéo de sa fille ciao